the beguile takes place it's in the
south
this is Civil War era South and you guys
shot on an actual plantation we did
whereabouts it was I'm in Thibodeau
which is like outside of New Orleans
it's called it was called the maid wood
plantation that yeah we shot in two
different locations in that way and that
was one it was a very special plantation
because it's also the film is mostly
it's all girls and like girls of all
ages like there's a lot of us in it so
um and then Colin obviously but we uh on
Farrell plays the soldier who comes in
he's wounded and you guys were taking
care of him a plantation and it's
beautifully done it's shot I mean first
of all the costumes were all very
authentic it's shot in this natural
light you really do feel like you're in
this plantation and it's the 19th
century yeah yeah yeah and also like a
nap that plantation it was special
because that's where Beyonce shot
lemonade the music video so obviously
all of us were freaking out and there's
a specific chair that was there that we
discovered and we're like this chair
looks familiar it was like one of the
girls discovered it and we asked the
owner we're like did this the Beyonce
chair and it's this chair that Serena
Williams and Beyonce there's like a
photo of them and so then obviously all
of us had to recreate the photo like we
took turns being Beyonce serene and
they're like okay now switch your Serena
and Beyonce like if we hoped this held
up product.this hold up production of
the movie six weeks yeah I think we have
a side-by-side here of the real
temperature and then you guys all taking
your turn
it's so funny that people are going to a
historic plantation and all that you
know that dates back to like the 1840s
and anybody's gonna want to ever see now
is the Beyonce chair yeah where's the
Beyonce chair
you